foreign
[Music]
stay here with rocket watch him that's
who they're coming for I want to come no
mantis watch Drax group
you know what to do with these
I am pushing down on it push the button
it looks like you're pushing the keyhole
the what there's a button under the
handle press that in
okay now what open the door
that is a stupid design and your
instructions were very unclear
we're the Guardians of the Galaxy all
the love you feel romantic sexual no no
I don't no
hold the laughs
no try again
led to this that is sad
foreign
people on Earth die when they're like
50. are you about to die I'm not 50.
fifth
so what should we do next start your
summer something good something bad with
a happy ending
knock it off what you got issues quill
oh come on
Guardians of the Galaxy volume three
only Peter's May 5th tickets on sale now
[Music]
thank you